well the string of deadly incidents in
the valley really extends into this past
weekend sunday night two motorcyclists
were killed in a crash near civic center
in cheyenne and one of them 53-year-old
parrish jones madison kimbrough spoke to
a friend of his who says this loss has
really made an impact on the motorcycle
community madison
yeah this deadly crash involved three
motorcycles and one suv two people
survived while two other people lost
their
lives i really can't even
imagine what that would even transpire
for this to even happen for him because
i know usually for him he's usually
cautious it's hard to fathom that sherry
hall is still in disbelief that her
friend of over 35 years is gone parrish
jones was one of the motorcyclists who
lost his life in a crash on sunday hall
believes jones was riding with his bike
club at the time and says this is a
wake-up call to a lot of his fellow
writer friends going to be missed by a
lot of our classmates have already um
placed a lot of posts
about this situation being that he was
on the motorcycle and being that they're
dangerous as well it's kind of hit home
to a lot of those different guys as well
because they actually ride bikes as well
dazzling venturo founder of the
motorcycle club bling divas mc in las
vegas says even though she didn't know
jones the amount of motorcycle
fatalities across the valley is
startling the amount of tragedy that
happened over the weekend
i just before we got on the phone saw
another fatality just minutes ago
earlier this morning two more accidents
everyone needs to respect the roads we
all need to
slow down be more careful
watch out be more respectful of the
other drivers that are out on the road
north las vegas police have not yet said
exactly how the crash happened and we're
still waiting to learn who the second
person killed was according to a
facebook group there will be a vigil
held for jones tomorrow reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now